folks. We are back for stream three of
today. Not a super good hours day
honestly. Kind of burnt myself out in
the second session going over all this
crazy stuff with this
algorithm. But um we are going to see if
it does anything.
tactical. I've actually really wanted
that
unfinished. That one's a bit hard for
you. There's like a lot of like classic
AI that you'd have to do.
It's based on the um like the MMO
Doofus. I've got like 3,000 hours in
that game growing up. Freaking awesome
game. The thing is it's still an awesome
game today. Like that and a Runescape
are the two games that have ever been
like straight up heroin for me.
What happened to game studios? I don't
know,
man. I can't think of like a
single modern game that I've really put
a lot of hours into. I guess Overwatch
is like kind
of, but like it's like I play that for
like a month or two
max. Yeah. Not even
anymore. Good thing we have better
things to do. We have more productive
things to do. We probably don't have
more fun things to do to be
honest. One of my best friends
um growing up like that I met on an MMO.
I met him like over the summer cuz he
turned out to be a he turned out to be a
software engineer as well and he's now
at uh he's now at
Meta which is pretty cool.
MMOs. I don't know what it
is. It's
like a lot of it is the fact that it's
like a self-contained like big thing
that you can like come up
with approaches to. And I don't even
[ __ ] know. It's like it's more of a
game than any other genre of game, I
guess. I don't know.
Like every other game has like a
gameplay loop, right? I think like an
MMO is the only thing that
has like a ton of gameplay loops and
just pick whatever gameplay loop you
figure that you feel like now and it all
somehow connects.
TTT output has no attribute squeeze.
What in the
hell time
training we train and test and we test
and
train. We are very smart.
Well, we're going to see whether it's a
meme, if it works or not.
I tried coding this thing myself and I
just failed because the paper makes no
bloody sense. What are you working on?
So there's this
paper. This is test time
training. It's an RNN where the hidden
state is a network that you train during
the forward pass of the RNN.
It's really weird, but this was used in
Nvidia's like recent one minute video
generation
paper.
Um, the thing is I read it and it looked
like really really Yeah, I know it's
crazy. Here it's roughly this. So
like here's your layer and in the
forward path of the layer you go over
all the tokens like of the sequence and
for each token you train the state
Because the state is actually a model
that gets initialized in the forward
pass. You take one gradient step per
token and then you use that model here
that you just
trained. So you actually develop like
you train the model over the course of
the
sequence. So it's kind of an interesting
idea, right?
Unfortunately, this code sucks and
doesn't remotely describe what it does
correctly. This description about the
batching and stuff is straight up wrong.
Uh, all the math is incredibly confusing
and misleading. And their code base is
confusing and misleading as hell as
well. So, it's just freaking confusing
on all fronts.
Can we call this on policy?
Sure. It's a free
country. It is
reproducible. Their code
works. It's just everything is confusing
as
hell. It's kind of like the idea is
good. The execution is good. Even the
communication of it all just sucks.
How big is the RNN? As big as you want
it to be. 9.3 million is way too big for
a puffer. So, I don't know what's going
on there.
uh,
date ttt cache
equals ttt cache
equal state.tt
cache. Now we have to do
[Music]
training. I don't think we have to do
any of that
there. So I think I can just
do
state.ttach. We don't even need
it. Got to see what the last uh hidden
state looks like.
This tensor has no attribute category.
Uhhuh.
Bro, what the heck is wrong with this
crazy thing?
in training here. It somehow messes this
up.
override. You got to be kidding me that
they did that.
I don't understand. Are you not supposed
to freaking train this thing? Like,
what's wrong?
Ash. One of my friends told me about
work. New here making a moral and focus
on cooperation between generally
competent
agents. What's the best way to reach out
to you to get your quick 30 secondond
thoughts? You're doing it right here.
Can I drop a link to our extended
abstract? Yes, you can. Feel like you'd
have an interesting perspective on our
dev. Yeah,
I was like I think I've heard that from
like people
torrenting music back in the day
maybe.
Uh whatever. You can steal all of
my highly confidential open source
research data.
Multi- aent environment for studying
emergent multi- aent role
specialization. That's my language.
This is not computationally accessible
in the least because it's slow as hell.
Smack.
I'm not going to lie, one of the first
things I started doing since I graduated
my PhD was like completely skipping
reading introduction sections. So, I
mean, this is fine. It's not for me.
Like, you don't have to sell me. It's
like, yes, we need Ms.
I will I would actually like to tell you
though I can scroll down. Okay. I would
like to tell you in
general if you actually like like
writing code and don't mind getting into
stuff a bit just drop jacks as an
environment engine. It's so [ __ ] Like
having to write all of your M's as
purely a series of array operations.
It's so constraining and it doesn't do
you any
favors. Have you seen the way that we
build our MS and
puffer? Yeah. So, this is like a mini
grid extension style
thing. So, I mean, here's here's this
the best cell for like the way that we
do our stuff. Okay.
Right. Try to implement this in Jacks.
Good
Oops. Oh, yeah. There's a market, by the
way, in case this looks like, oh, maybe
I could do this in jacks.
Well, the thing is that Craftax is like
it would have been easier and it would
have been faster in C. I like I don't
even have Craft X actually. I have a
collab with their lab, but like Craftex
is slow by tougher standards. It's 10
times too slow and it's on a GPU. It
would be 10 times faster on one CPU
core, you see? And it would have been
easier to write. There's just no reason
to torture yourself like this. I mean,
we've got the MOA, right? All these
different MS and we don't have to think
about stupid array based programming at
all. Like this is one file. Okay, so
this is like arguably one of the most
complex MS out there right now. Uh
particularly like complex plus fast. You
can't really do better than
that. Here's the code.
So this is shorter than Craft
X. It's 2,800 lines and if you read it,
it's brained it. Like the code is
brained it easy and it runs over 1.5
million steps per
second. It's literally just four loops
if statements. Like there's nothing
remotely smart or intelligent about the
code here. It's just what if we just
write brain dead simple code and
see like you can just see nothing's like
super deeply indented. There's no super
long lines. It's just bore for if yada
yada yada continue all the code you just
read it top to bottom. A first year
undergrad who's taken one systems course
can read
this right and if I want to add anything
to this it's super easy. I just edit
arbitrary code. No need to think about
array
programming. So yeah, I mean we have way
simpler examples than this to get you
started as well. But uh for people who
are like seriously wanting to build new
RLMs, I highly highly suggest it. And as
a bonus, you get to run them on the web
for free. So you get to have your M's
online playable for free. Same exact
code. You know what they had to do for
kinetics? And I got to actually chat
with these guys because this is awesome
work. It's just they made their lives
way harder than it should have been.
Look, look how cool this thing is,
right? Like you can build these ends. Do
you know what they had to do to make
this work? They had to take all the code
that they just written their thousands
and thousands of lines of jacks and
rewrite all of it in JavaScript just to
get this
demo. If they'd written it the way that
I suggested, it would have been shorter.
the original code would be shorter and
simpler and you would just compile it
for web and be
done. It's crazy,
right? So, literally Jack is like fine
as a training thing, right? Like
whatever. Not my cup of tea because it's
like weird functional object-oriented
hodge podge, but like fine. Jacks for
environments was researchers not knowing
how to program. That's
it. Oh, and you want to know something
even
crazier? If you actually do want to
write, if you actually do want to write
a GPU environment, you can copy and
paste simple C into CUDA and it'll run
cuz CUDA is just C that runs on your
GPU. So there you go. Your same code
will run on the
GPU. Now admittedly, for more complex
stuff, you kind of have to think about
it a little bit more, but not that much.
So cool M. We absolutely need more M's.
If something like this were submitted to
Puffer Live as a PR, I will be like
delighted to have cool new M to study
stuff with like this. But you're making
your life hard on yourself with
jacks. Let me see what you got for state
space.
Uh, this is fine. I would just I just
flatten the Well, you can see the
engineering optimizations we do to make
state stuff fast, but this data is
fine.
Discrete action space is awesome. Super
easy to implement. I mean, super easy to
like implement networks for
Yeah, coordination and stuff like this
all super
cool. Make it super fast. Make it super
easy to use. Train some cool models on
it. I would highly suggest trying out
the puffer style of stuff with this. I
think you'll have a good time.
like this type of a thing
here. Even with uh without even having
like a Jax compile trainer, just with
our PyTorch, you can easily train this
over a million steps per second. Does
not train. Barely
works. Yeah.
If you're interested in sticking around
Puffer, if you want to have if you want
to submit something like this to Puffer,
we would be
here. It says who made the M.
This one is
bets and uh you literally just you pip
install puffer limp and you can play the
end
immediately. Oh, also this is a
superhuman neural network playing the
game in your browser and I can hold
shift and I can take over for it. Now
I'm playing and I'm bad and now I can
let the bot take over and the bot will
be superhuman again.
fun. But yeah, welcome to my uh my
personal crusade to make reinforcement
learning fast and easy. That is what
this is.
kind of frustrated with the
jacks.
Yep. There's a learning curve with C,
but it is so much easier. So much
easier. I wrote Python for 10 years. It
took me like 2, three weeks and I was
perfectly happy in C. And now it pisses
me off that I have to write Python most
of the time. I am way happier just
jamming C environments all day.
But don't go too crazy with this C. The
key is to just keep it super simple.
Single
pointers, for loops, if statements, no
crazy macros. You just write really
simple code. All static
memory, no crazy memory management. It's
just really easy.
And yeah, hang around. It's
discord.gg/pbuffer. We all just hang out
and build RL stuff all
day. What do you mean static memory? We
allocate all the memory that we need for
the environment at the start. We don't
bother reallocating memory midway
through. That's not remotely a
constraint at all, by the way. We do
multi- aent, we do variable agent, we do
all sorts of stuff. It's still easy.
You still malic, but you malic at the
start. And then you don't like do a
whole bunch of mallets you have to keep
track of. You don't slow stuff down with
that. It's really easy. Here, let me let
me show you the snake code just you can
see just how how truly easy stuff like
this
is. Usually no pointers to pointers.
Yep. Okay. So, puff snake is our multi-
aent demo, right? Snake is a pretty cool
environment as well. Like snake is
pretty darn cool to look at. This thing
trains at two million steps per second.
By the way, so this is multi- aent
snake. It's snake with a whole bunch of
snakes. 2 million snake snake steps per
second training with a little CNN LSTM.
I believe CNN LSTM. This one might just
be CNN. We'll see. But uh here's the
code. Snake.h H 325 lines after the
refactor in the new branch. This is
going to be about 270 lines because we
don't need this logging crap anymore.
You make a strct. This strct is your
environment. It's got some data. You
make some
init. You have a free but like you alloc
once, you free once. That's it. This is
your compute observation function.
444. That's it. This is how you delete a
snake from the game. This is how you
spawn a snake into the game. This is how
you spawn food. This is how you reset
the end. This is how you step the
snake. Little bit of logic for stepping
the
snake. That's all the
code. This is the client. This is how we
render it. Really, it's just this bit of
code right here. Super
easy. That's it.
runs at like tens of millions of steps
per second. The actual environment
itself on one CPU
core, you compile it with the flags that
we have, you'll get nice clean error
messages, better error messages than
Python even. You don't you don't get
stupid seg faults to debug. Um, you just
get like clean air messages with address
sanitizer. We have SYON bindings, but
actually in the new version, we have
made the bindings even easier. The new
binding code is like really easy.
Actually, did I do it for Snake
yet? I wonder if I did it for
Snake. I didn't do it for Snake yet. But
we have new binding code that makes it
like really easy to bind these to
Python. That's it.
So, I don't know what in what capacity
you do RL stuff, but if you're looking
for a cool open source place to do some
research and sling some code,
We also give um compute access to
contributors around
here.
So if you need stuff to run experiments
on and you're actually contributing
code, we also give access to uh
boxes. Oh, you got compute. That's cool.
Most universities have terrible compute,
so that is solid. I I got my own after I
finished my PhD. And this is way better
than anything I had at
MIT. We're getting more of these. By the
way,
um as soon as the tariff situation
revolves
itself, as soon as the tariff situation
revolves, uh resolves itself. We're
buying 40 of these.
MIT cluster is
insane. No, the machines really, really,
really sucked, especially for
RL. Each one of these boxes uh has been
like three times faster than $100,000
server for the purposes of a lot of RL
stuff. And these are like five grand a
piece. Yeah. So contributors, we just
give people SSH access to boxes. It's a
fun
time. Mainly the clusters have two slow
CPUs for all the older M's. It doesn't
matter as much now, but um like it
doesn't matter as much now that our Ms
are super
fast, but
uh for like Atari and stuff before when
we were doing that, the CPUs were
awful. And that's uh this is B in the
discord as
well. He is resident puffer
procelite advertises of all things
puffer.
thing? Can I just use the TTGT layer?
Hang on.
Oh yeah, I made um I made us a cool
thing lately for
bindings. So this file is kind of a
mess.
I'm trying to clean this up, but
basically I wrote this 500ish line file
which uses just the Python C native API.
And yeah, this is kind of a mess. But
the cool thing about doing this is that
now instead of having to write this
massive shitty Syon file for every
single end and you just do this, this is
the binding for breakout now. So this is
all the code that is needed to bind this
to uh from C to Python.
You just define variables that need to
go from Python to
C and
you figure out what variables you want
to extract as logs and that's
it. So it's pretty
cool. One of the fun things around here,
right, is we have people that like to
help with infra. We have people that
like to help with some of the
engineering work. We have people who
like to help with experiments. Lots of
stuff.
And yeah, B is right. Anybody can learn
this. Bet is a relatively new
programmer. Bet. How long you been doing
this? Like less than two years,
right? year and a few months of writing
like any code at all. Like there you
go. To be fair, he is a trooper.
Like I uh I gave him this project to do.
I massively underestimated how hard of a
project this was going to be for like a
new programmer and he still did it.
He did it with like two to three times
too much code at the start, but then he
like he trimmed it down and now it's
actually pretty
reasonable. And this is like one of my
favorite MS now. Look how freaking cool
this thing is to watch. It's like just
so
mesmerizing. It's so cool. I love this
M. It's just like this classic Atari
game, but it's like one of the cooler
ones. It's like actually a racing game.
Well, I don't know. Maybe I'm going to
start writing stuff and assembly next.
We'll
see. Plus, puffer shipping custom
assembly.
H I don't know. We've been shipping CUDA
lately. It's the only next thing I could
do.
See you around. I'm mostly streaming dev
pretty much always.
So, drop on
by. Always use new contributors.
puffer. We're almost at 2K. 2K on puffer
is going to be
awesome. Got to hit 2k on puffer and 10k
on
X. Be pretty solid base.
So I think the easiest
thing to do
here is going to just be to modify the
layer to take the mini back
frames directly.
Wait, this doesn't use the cache params,
right?
thing doesn't look like it uses the
cache params.
You don't need to cash at all on crane.
I don't think
Yes, I figured seating it with like
reasonable data would be better. It
probably should be seated with like the
optimal hypers or whatever that you
found. I don't know.
latest
run. I set the means to be the last
optimal. Now, that's a good idea.
Yeah. So, this thing doesn't do much,
does it?
Bad. That thing isn't training. I'm so
Wait, what thing isn't
training?
This. Yeah, obviously this isn't
training. What's
happening? Uh, I tried to implement it
and I couldn't get it to train. Uh, and
then I tried their thing and I can't get
it to train either.
It does work
though. Oh, really?
What happens if we don't use this cash?
Didn't I have something working if like
we just don't use the
cash? Wasn't it like ironically doing
better without the cash?
model? 360. So, this is a
chunker. This is a chunker.
I thought I had it doing something a bit
ago, didn't I?
I can't say that the results are
particularly encouraging here
though better like
literally was
better and this for 40 mil literally
does better without the
I had this thing doing something before,
didn't
I? And we're not going to try [ __ ]
with custom hydro frames a whole
bunch. Okay, that's what I thought. It
does actually eventually start doing a
thing.
How hard would it be to make this thing
fast? Like very right.
I thought I had like it running
something at one
point. Was it just me leaving this
running for longer? I don't think so.
Right. Did it just like take off at one
point? I don't think so.
I mean, I wouldn't call it working.
Like, it sort of
trained. It still wasn't like
good. This is probably it.
Maybe not. Oh, hang on. Maybe this is
still not the right one. That could just
be prior
replay. Yeah, I do think that I saw
something like this
though. But this is still not good
perf.
Right. Okay. Yeah, I mean at least that
is like definitely learning,
right? I That's good enough that I can
commit it.
curve. I can do one more experiment
after this, I
guess. Warm start.
does. Ah, it's so [ __ ] slow, though.
Look at this thing. This is double the
size of the previous model, and it's
just so slow.
They say is it's literally 100 times
faster than the average RL researchers
code. But it should be a thousand times
faster. It's so
slow. I don't think this thing's
freaking I not even Neptune
this. Is it not here?
one. I mean, this is
like not great.
It could solve it eventually, but it's
[ __ ] breakout like anything
should. Some messages real quick.
Yeah, that's
TTT. I uh I'm very much looking forward
to not looking at
this. Well crap. Now it's 853 and we
didn't really get to do much VR any VR
stuff at all today.
We can try one thing real quick.
That's V trace
here. I was thinking
um a little bit
about the loss with
Vray and I was thinking
here that you get this like
clamped loss,
It should be positive advantage here not
negative Okay.
really. This clamping is not going to do
it.
Okay. So, this is the same curve. Then
you're telling me that this messes it up
somehow? Like this doesn't train at all
somehow.
That's
bizarre. So, you can't clamp this for
some weirdo
it? Can you norm
it and then clamp
huh? There's something screwy with the
way V trace works. Like, you can't clip
it. And you'd really, really, really,
really want to be able to clip
it. I mean, I can clip the advantage
technically.
What do you clip in this? Can you like
You can't clip anything,
right? I had to go to bed soon,
but I'm annoyed that I didn't get to
work on this at all today. I kind of
just gassed out on
I don't know why I'm scrolling like
this. I I got to go to bed shortly cuz
I'm like really losing uh the focus. But
I like I just want to see if there's
something we can do with this, right?
actions. Do you want to clip the
advantage, not the loss?
This is
logic. This is actions.
this? It's crazy that clipping
completely breaks this,
big ass
moth my
face.
Um I don't know. Let's try clipping the
advantage. Then I'm going to bed.
I don't expect that to work to be
honest. I think I'm going to have to
think about this more deeply
tomorrow. So, we kind of figured out
from PO before that the clamping was
really
important. Now, you're not going to give
me this error on this totally different
algorithm. What the heck is this?
Yeah, clipping the advantage really
screws you
over. It's like surprisingly bad as
well, isn't
Man, what happens if you just
[Music]
previous? It
is. Dang. I thought we had something.
No, we definitely don't have
something that's negative
advantage. I mean, I'm sure it's not
going to work if I do this,
right? The ratio needs to be negative,
right?
It's the fact that it like hard fails on
a lot of demons. To me, it's like
there's a quirk or a bug or something.
It's not just like Yeah, it's just
worse, right? It's like there's a quirk
or a bug cuz like it's pretty darn good
on
Breakout and then it just hard fails on
some other
tasks. Anyways, I'm gonna try uh I
probably this will be the first thing I
do in the morning. We'll see. I got lots
to work
on. Try to get in the time. I guess
tomorrow I got to run first thing in the
morning. So, we'll do that and then I'll
come to this. Um but for folks
watching, all my stuff is open source.
It's here buffer.ai. Lots of fun
demos. If you want to help me out for
free, just start at the GitHub. almost
at 2k stars. It's going to be pretty
nice. Helps him out a lot. If you want
to get involved in dev, you don't need
an RL background. Just need to know how
to program. Join the Discord. Some of
our best contributors came in with
actually no experience whatsoever, but
programming background does help. Um,
and other than that, you can follow me
on X for more RL content. I post lots of
mostly RL
things. blog here, quick start guide,
other useful resources, but there's more
on X you can't get anywhere else.